well inaction is not exactly dropping
out my objection to action is it assumes
understanding in order to act you have
to know what should be done who can
claim to know what should be done that I
had interviewed ROM das in Prague this
summer and it completely blew my mind
the guy actually believes he knows what
should be done
he doesn't doubt his own judgement I was
well it's amazing to me it just I just
I've never known a moment of that kind
of certitude about what was going on
it's like interviewing a Martian for me
I think you know this person believes
they understand what's going on bizarre
I feel it the way you would touch a
Maserati you we don't know what's going
on for example I mean we mentioned the
asteroid thing we want to save the
rainforest it seems perfectly rational
to wish to save the rainforest
if however and we already have one
example of this occurring an asteroid is
going to strike the earth in the next
10,000 years saving the rainforest
appears to be a completely stupid place
to put energy what we should have been
doing was learning how to blow up
asteroids our heart was in the right
place the impulse was good save the
earth but we completely misperceived the
dimension of danger well sure but then
there are 10 other of these things as
well or 20 other so better to believe I
think that how can it possibly be that
the fate of things comes to rest on a
talking monkey what kind of car
most would write a script like that far
more likely that we just simply are a
self-important monkey and so we run
around saying you know we must do
something you mean from the planet well
don't you think we must have been doing
there must be some essential ripeness to
where we've come to hear that yes it
represents high risk it would have been
less risky if there had been no human
civilization but on the other hand a
whole bunch of things wouldn't exist
that do exist and nature is truly
mysterious truly beyond rational
apprehension and so the best thing is a
religious attitude of reverent
psychedelic aw and the faith in the
dynamics of the thing and and like that
basically faith in the larger dynamics
that we can't possibly have gotten loose
from the control systems that keeps the
stars in their orbits and the oceans
moving it's just that this represents an
experiment of some sort I mean it many
times in the Earth's history remember
that once oxygen was a toxic gas and all
life on Earth was under threat from the
accumulation of oxygen solving that
problem laid the basis for eukaryotic
life once there were no flowering plants
and the death of the climaxed ecosystem
I dare say rain forests from here to
everywhere gone in a sing
moment and there's an older scar where
the same thing happened so it's I think
it's important to live and to be but the
anxiety of the uncompleted plan I think
is a misperception the Chinese guy we
Poe Yang said worry is preposterous
worry is preposterous you don't know
enough to worry and and I think concern
is legitimate concern but it's more it's
we're watching a beautiful game unfold
and I don't say that it won't end with
the extinction of the human species I
mean if we can absorb something like
this asteroid hit then but but the whole
thing is it is it is no species controls
its destiny no species ever has control
of its destiny and this species is no
exception this is a dynamic larger than
that and the fact that it's so much
about freedom and the illusion of
control is part of the fascinating dance
[Music]
you